[Music]
on today's show we talk to a woman who
is dealing with religious trauma and
trying to heal her relationship with her
dad
we talk about the ongoing mental health
crisis in america we talked to an
incredible young man who is really
struggling with anxiety and he's ready
to heal stay tuned
[Music]
yo yo yo what up this is john with the
dr john dalone show
talk about mental health relationships
education schools kids parents
all of it
your dating relationships your marriage
whatever's going on in your life give me
a call 1-844-693-3291
that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask
and while you are there
man i'm beating this drum
sorry not sorry i'll keep doing it for a
season
new book own your past change your
future is out
for pre-sale
if you order it on pre-sale it comes
with all this extra stuff
ebooks and uh the
uh
what's not the e-book the audiobook
the other kinds of the books that's
right free counseling from better health
for a month i mean tons of stuff on
there
and the book's good and i feel good
about it
it's strong and if you bought my last
book and um
uh it's this one's a real book it's a
big one not the last one it wasn't real
but the one was little it's a quick read
this is a full-size book it's a real
book and i am excited about it go to
johndolone.com
fill out a form to be on the show and
while you're there go ahead and
pre-order the book let's go to
danny is it danny
austin
danny let's go to danny in boston
massachusetts what's up danny
hi dr d how are you
i'm good doing good how are you just
saving the world i you know what i
probably overstated that a little bit i
don't think i am saving the world but
we're having fun how about you
i'm doing good i got i got to talk to
kelly when she called me which is
probably the worst so far like the most
exciting part of this and i'm really
excited to talk to you was she mean to
you
she was amazing i know
i know that's what she does she has all
your folks on the phone thinking she's
so kind and wonderful and then we have
to live with her just kidding she's
incredible she's like the best kelly's
the best
she is he's awesome so what's up how can
i help
yeah so thanks so much for taking my
call
um i think
you know i have uh my i'm struggling
with my my dad
um he's part of a very fundamentalist
christian community and they have a very
specific view on religion and
interpretation of the bible and that
theirs is the only like right way to
live uh it is it is
there are no other ways
they figured it out
but go ahead
yeah and so i think as i've gotten older
and i have children and i have i have
you know i left that community when i
was
in my early 20s um
i'm struggling to have a relationship
with him he's he's you know he's always
been there for me like he'll talk to me
but every conversation is about
you know it's it's he always gets he
always gets the little
snippets in and it just feels like a
constant reminder that
he thinks i'm not living my life the way
of raising my kids the way that it
should be and that he has to save me so
and i'm just really struggling with that
conversation with him
can i just tell you i hate that for you
yeah thank you um
so
go back to childhood you left this group
why'd you leave
was it a belief issue was it the way
they treated you was it the way the
things they said why'd you leave
so
um
so so i i was so
why'd i leave that's a good question
um they
[Music]
just say it out loud say it out loud say
it out loud i know it's hard to i know
hey i know that i am poking at some deep
deep stuff
as much as you feel comfortable just
saying it out loud
yeah
so they do practice shunning and um at
the time i was stunning married shunning
yep so like if you like dwight and jim
like shun
yeah just like joy and jim yeah listen
i've worked with all kinds of religious
communities my whole career
i've never
i'm not i'm not mocking i never heard of
this so what does that mean like okay we
turn our back on you like we shun
um um it's yep it's intended to be to be
loving like your
your
one of your flock has gone astray and
you know and they'll they'll realize
that they made a mistake and come back
into your loving arms kind of thing i
thought jesus went left the 99 went and
got that other one
that's a good it's a good point yeah
okay so okay so back that thing up so
you no i shouldn't say that out like
don't you don't back that thing up i'm
backing up um so
they shunned
yeah so i i basically so i was married i
was married very young i found myself in
a not great relationship um
so i left but i basically preemptively
personally cut off
almost all ties because i knew the other
option was they were gonna
sort of
do it for me so i when i was 25 i
i essentially like completely started
over now my my dad or my like my he
never
he never cut me off so i still have that
really yeah
i still have that relationship um but
you know it's um
it you you know like you know they
they feel
that
you're making a tragic mistake right and
that it's their job to try to so that
they give you like you that's in the
back of your mind in every conversation
so the
shunning like
you you got a divorce you got married
young
and there were some things in that
marriage that didn't so you got divorced
and you knew by making this decision to
leave your husband and do something else
with your life
that was also going to cost you your
faith community and so instead of going
through their trial or whatever
um yeah
rick and mary they're going to put you
through you just said deuces i'm out my
guess is there's more to it than that
that you left for bigger reasons than
just they were going to be mean to you
and so you preempted you shunned them
before they shut unto you
but
here's what i'm asking
yeah
so there's
we have belief
disagreements with people
so let's take something that's not that
big of a deal like vaccination status
right
and that's me being facetious of
everyone's
it's the whole thing
um
i get
that somebody looks at the data and
believes the right thing for me to do is
to get vaccinated
i also
understand why someone would say i'm
looking at all of the chaos and saying i
want no part of that
until there's some clarity
and then i also understand
less so but i understand that there's
some guy in the trunk of his car with a
youtube channel with 11 followers and
he's like guess what's happening now and
that you think that's the person who's
discovered truth i get that too right
all right all three of them
but ultimately those are you're gonna
come down on belief issues and you're
gonna hang out and go have a drink with
somebody and then they're gonna be like
bro you know you should be in they're
gonna give you their spiel whatever
their spiel happens to be
those are belief issues fine
that's different
when there's trauma at the bottom of it
so we've heard about when it comes to
vaccinations that
african-american community might have
some challenges because they remember
the tuskegee
be like hey we're not walking into some
emergency authorization use thing we've
done this before and y'all used it to
poison i mean you know what i mean yeah
yeah yeah in your case
you get to like this isn't just about
hey you should be going to this church
or we're going to that one
if there's trauma at the bottom of this
if there were things told to you about
how women were or should be or
the way you were treated or the way you
were told to shun people who were
hurting
into loving them whatever the things are
if there's a trauma basis here your
body's gonna get set off
and that's different than a belief
difference hear what i'm saying
yes when somebody believes
i need like we're having a medical
disagreement on the vaccine that's one
thing when somebody believes the
government's trying to kill my kids it's
a different response whether i believe
them or not i get that response is
visceral
right or someone doesn't have the
vaccine i believe my neighbor's trying
to murder my family right i get that
there's a there's a visceralness so
where where are you on this is it just a
belief difference
or did you walk out of this thing
because
there was some trauma there there was
some hurt there
um
i think
so yeah so
i don't i don't know that i've i don't
i don't know that i walked out um
so the marriage wasn't great like
um
there was anger issues
but um which i i didn't i wanted no part
of i wanted
to you know before it escalated so i i
that was part of it but um
the fact hey listen
the fact that you think you owe some
knuckleheaded podcaster on the radio an
explanation as to why you left your
marriage that many years ago
tells me you've got some
that you were told that your job is to
make sure everybody's okay and everybody
approves of your decisions before you
move forward
yeah i mean my dad was
he was pretty angry growing up he never
that's all you're gonna say it's like
that's all you gotta say that's all
you're going to say
so the when i'm talking to you about
what this what this group left in you
and on you
your body's responding right now right
yeah yeah yeah okay
so let's fast forward to the original
question that you asked
[Laughter]
here's why we're here
this isn't a matter of
like dad i don't believe in shunning i
believe in hugging and we're just gonna
have to we're gonna have to
we're just gonna have to call a spade a
spade on that one
this is not that
this is your dad is trying to bring you
to something that he thinks in his heart
is gonna help you
yes and that your body knows hurt you
and by your
by the tears being so close
it still hurts you it's still in you
yeah right
there's still unresolved trauma there
that you and i could probably go hang
out and have a beer and talk about it
for a long long time right
the point here is this
you do not have to put your body in that
situation and you don't have to put your
kids in that situation because that's
the other part is you don't want your
kids to experience what you experience
true yes and so
the big magic word here is boundary
and that's a simple word but it's hard
because and it's devastating because you
know the other side of shunning
is you lose your dad
and here's what i need you to hear me
say
that's his choice not yours
yes and that sucks
we will go to the ends of the earth to
not put our parents in a position to
choose something over us when we know
they're going to choose the other thing
yeah
we don't want to face that reality so we
just put up with it and put up with it
and put up with it and then all of a
sudden we even parted that on our kids
and then they do it and then they do it
and they do it and then it gets passed
on generation after generation after
generation
yeah
so somebody has to stare the sucker down
and say
if you bring up this again
you're my dad
i love you
um it sounds to me like you've got some
stuff you need to work through with a
counselor about your dad
um
not probably 100 chance 100 chance
are you married now
yes yes good guy
amazing i'm very blessed if he was
behind you and heard me say you should
probably go to counselor and get work on
some of your dad's stuff he would
probably be nodding his head vigorously
right
he would be very supportive yes you i'm
sure he would so
for you go do that okay okay
and there's gonna be some stuff about
your dad you're gonna have to face it's
gonna be ugly and messy and gross and
you don't wanna think about it cause you
love him and he is a good guy
but you gotta stare that stuff down
because your body knows
yeah and when he calls your heart beats
a little bit faster and when he says
he's coming over
your heart beats a lot faster and you go
a little bit more limbic and you're a
little bit more tense and you hold cups
a little bit tighter and all of that
energy and electricity gets passed on
and passed on to past on and i want you
to be able to sleep
and we we did have um
a conversation
and it was exactly kind of how you
describe like i just i just snapped like
i come i felt like after it was over
i was like what what beings took over my
body like words were coming out that i
didn't even like like things i felt that
were buried so deep i don't know that i
ever acknowledged and i i asked him i
was like i can't like i can't have i
can't can't keep having these
conversations with you like i need to
have a relationship that revolves
that's more than this he's had some
health issues so it's it's been him
almost dying or
it's been you know this for the past
like three years and um
he he he doesn't he doesn't under he's
very
and like he tries to understand and he
just but he doesn't and i and i if i
feel like i tried i'm not good at
boundaries i know that i feel like i
tried really hard and now i'm feeling so
uncomfortable because i feel like
there's this unsettled problem between
us and i don't
do that so listen
there is an unsettled problem between
the two of you
and you can't fix it
and that's the
that's the heartbreaking part you can't
solve it
he can because he's dead
yeah and i know that hurts
you can't fix that one
and
i just thought of this just now
but i can imagine a world where your
body
your brain your heart feels like a
boundary protecting you and your kids
is akin to shunning and some part of you
swore i will never shun anybody for
anything for any reason
and so here's what i want you to think
through
a boundary is not a shun
a boundary is you simply saying this is
what i need to be okay and if you are
willing to help me be well
or to love me enough or to respect me
enough or to have enough dignity be a
person of character enough to listen to
the things that i need to be well
i am yours and you're mine
and if you choose
your things over the things i'm telling
you out loud
i need to feel safe and feel well
then you are choosing to not be a part
of my life and that breaks my heart but
that's your choice
you see how everything about this is his
choice
except for the boundaries except for
your choice to take care of you and your
kids and your husband
great
and i hate hate hate that you have to do
this but you do
yeah i hate it for you
i'm okay i am
whenever my six-year-old daughter is
sprinting through the house and all of a
sudden we just hear wham and she crashes
it she'll you'll hear this i'm okay
exactly she's clearly not okay she
doesn't want us to get up and go see
what she's trying to sneak into the room
you're clearly not okay danny and listen
it's okay to not be okay
you're right this is gonna hurt
it's gonna hurt
and that's still okay
it's right
yes yeah so here's what i want you to do
you've heard me say this a million times
i'm gonna say it a million more times
i want you
to write a letter to your dad
okay about everything
all of it
you can even have sections called good
stuff and bad stuff
i don't care what it is
as a part of the letter at the end i
want you to say so now what
and that's what i want you to articulate
after you've written the good stuff the
stuff that you love about them
actually you've really i want you to
like you just said i felt like i was
possessed something took over me i want
you to bring that i want you let your
limbic brain take back over for a minute
i want you to go there
yeah and then i want you to write down
so here's what's not acceptable in my
life anymore i'm choosing
to be well and here's what that's going
to look like for me
and then i want you to read this letter
out loud to your husband
okay
because he doesn't know it all does he
no nope
don't you read out loud to him
okay
and then i want you to call a counselor
and make an appointment
yeah okay i mean i need the counselor to
help me write the letter it's the whole
idea is terrifying so it is no issue
you may have to write two or three you
may have to write two or three yeah
okay
you may have to yeah
there's a moment that it's going to
happen that you're going to realize your
dad is somebody who is
intentionally
disregarding
your requests
for how you can best be loved
and that disregard is violence
it's immaturity and it has to stop
and most of us
hope that our parents will be the ones
to stop doing violence
and often we're the ones that have to
put up the boundaries and say no more
i mean yeah yeah it all makes sense it's
all very
logical i wish i had seven easy steps to
fix this i don't yeah i need the baby
steps for uh
exactly
well hey buy my new book and
i wish i had a man i wish i did
hey but here's the thing hang on the
line here's what i'm gonna do okay i'm
going to um austin's
kelly's at home she doesn't work on
these days just kidding she's actually
not she's actually sick she's not doing
she's not she's not feeling well uh we
miss her um but austin uh is here and i
want you to stay on the line we're gonna
get you get your information and i'm
gonna get you hooked up for the
pre-order of my new book that will walk
through these things with you
and um you have that but i'm only doing
that if you promise you'll write that
letter read it to your husband and make
a counseling appointment cool
i promise same team same dream
same team same team same dream i'm
trying to think of the cheesiest things
i could say i can't even see the stream
all right cool all right danny you're
awesome awesome awesome thanks for
calling we'll be right back on the dr
john de loni show
do you want a better life a better
marriage better mental and physical
health
the single most important action you can
take to improve your mental and physical
health to change your entire life
is to get enough deep restorative
quality sleep i know this from research
and as a guy who has struggled with
sleep for my entire life and for me good
sleep starts with a world-class mattress
that's why my family sleeps on dream
cloud mattress dream cloud is advanced
technology and you can buy in the store
or you can do it like i did and have it
shipped directly to your house dream
cloud is running their biggest offer
ever exclusively for dr john daloni show
listeners 399 bucks and accessories plus
an additional 250 discount that's a
total of
649 dollars in accessories and savings
pillows mattress protectors luxury
sheets all of it it's time to stop
sleeping on your old college mattress or
the old hand-me-down from grandma and
start changing your life visit
dreamcloudsleep.com or dreamcloudsleep
and enter promo code deloney and get
your new mattress today
hey we are back um
i want to take a minute
to go over this article that just came
out um
by the time this comes out this will be
several weeks old but
um
it's here off of yahoo.com one of the
cornerstones of of
non-biased reporting right
good news
but this is a this is out everywhere so
um actually it's come to usa today
it's in washington an overwhelming
majority of americans believe the u.s is
in the grips of a full-blown mental
health crisis
nearly two years into the cove 19
pandemic which brought a rise in
depression anxiety stress addiction
other challenges almost nine in 10
registered voters
believe there's a mental health
crisis in the nation
though it might be rare to find such
agreement in a nation divided over so
many issues mental health experts say
they're not surprised
man
a couple of things
yes i
100 agree there's a mental health crisis
i have felt it
even the last month for me
has been hard
this is the first time i have felt
dispari
i have felt
like literally what is going on
i look at some of the states that
um
have
pulled
you know
police forces when i look at some of the
states that have when i look at some of
this
i don't even want to get into that when
i look at some of the crime stuff when i
look at some of the
nonsensical
just people being dishonest about the
medical data on both sides by the way
so you're probably like yeah oh both
sides
people being
telling their kids
that your teachers want to kill you
because of the masks or not the masks
that your churches
don't believe in god because of the
masks not the mass when
your politicians want to murder you and
control you
yeah our kids cornerstone institutions
we have made them nuts with our own
insecurity
and now our kids can't anchor into
anything
and some of this is
our mental health crisis is getting
bonkers yes some of this is a great
revealing we weren't okay our marriages
were a wreck
where we put stock into
that we just took for granted that just
some package will show up on my house
every day and it's gonna be three days
i'm like what is it happening
and that the economy's just gonna buzz
along and we're just gonna keep printing
money forever i mean all these things we
just took for granted this is gonna be
the way this is it's not we are living
in a sliver of a snapshot of history
that is bonkers for how good things are
that volcano that just erupted the other
day guys that could be anywhere
anywhere the one off tonga off the coast
we just have fallen into this lullaby
this is just where this is i can just
never sleep and watch netflix 24 7. i
can never exercise i can eat whatever
crap i want i can be a complete jerk to
the people i work with i can just do it
i can drive i can
and then all of a sudden that stuff
stops
and our identity is not in i can do hard
stuff
and i will always treat people with
kindness and dignity no matter what and
i can exchange
difficult conversations and hard ideas i
can go back and forth and learn and i
can listen and i can say i'm wrong
all that's completely out the window
right now
and it is i'm right
always you're wrong always
they are
them
others
and our bodies are
screaming to get our attention
screaming to get our attention
and so there's no surprise that
good grief
i mean
the surgeon general man
murthy used the words crisis in calling
for a swift and coordinated response to
mental health challenges in children
adolescents and young adults we canceled
school
we cancelled the place where millions of
kids eat
where they get human connection
we just pulled them out
or when
or when they did go it was then
yeah here's the thing someone needs to
stand up and say hey
we messed up
and here's what we're gonna do now
well somebody please
stand up and say here's what we're going
to do now
i think most mental health diagnostics
again i'm way oversimplifying that you
psychologists and doctors and whatever i
know we can have talk shop someday
over a drink that's not for this
most mental health
crisis can be distilled down to a body
that does not feel safe that does not
feel connected
or that does not feel autonomy in
control of its thoughts its movements
its actions and you take those three
things and you
blanket them over our country right now
and that's what we get
so what's the step forward
commit
to being a person that says i change my
mind
commit to being a person that says i
will connect even if it's uncomfortable
if you have lost friendships or
parenting parent relationships or
sibling relationships over the last two
years
stop
call and say i'm sorry
not for my opinion i can think what i
want to think but i'm sorry that i let
something get between us
let's heal this
if you
are
obsessed with youtube rabbit holes get
off
if you're obsessed with social media
rifles get
off live in your neighborhood where your
home is what's that mean james we saw
the other day
walmart's taking out patents
uh
what virtual home purchases virtual
goods like curtains and tables and so
number one if i'm buying imaginary
things from imaginary house not buying
them from walmart i'm gonna go somewhere
awesome like dillard's is even awesome i
don't know if that's cool weston i'm
going to go somewhere more awesome to be
honest with you no bash on walmart i
shop at walmart but i mean that's just
what i'm going to do let's be honest um
but now we're buying
appliances that don't exist for homes
that don't exist that's we're buying
electronics and home goods
for homes that don't exist
what are we doing what are we doing
we're not having sex anymore
with our spouses we're not hanging out
with our buddies anymore we've just
stopped going to church we've stopped
doing things that keep us well we've
just quit exercising if you look at the
self-help sales of books
now i'm not all about self-help books
even i just wrote one
but people have just said screw it
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna take care of
myself
all of that stuff is just tanking
people just said whatever
whatever
hear me say you're worth it you're worth
it you're worth it god almighty you're
worth it
get with somebody you trust give it a
counselor get with someone and say i
gotta start anew today
because these mental health crisis
a 1.9 trillion dollar coronavirus relief
package passed last march includes
billions of dollars to prevent and treat
mental health and substance abuse
disorders
so many of this stuff starts in our
house
quit telling your kids that your
teachers want to kill them stop
quit telling them that doctors all want
them dead stop telling the government's
trying to kill them quit you're going to
make your kids bananas
start saying things like people are
doing the best they can with the info
they got
i disagree with some of that information
but i know people are working hard
stop gripping the wheels so tightly when
somebody's driving too fast because they
may be on the way to the hospital to
visit their dying wife
let
go
be grateful take care of your body your
family your spirit your health and those
around you and those you love
and i've never been a preachy guy on
this show man but enough is enough
start taking care of each other and
control the things you can control
[Music]
and if you see someone there's huge
inequities and access to care very very
true if you see somebody who needs help
help them out
god's sake help them out
it's a beautiful chance to start over
when you hit the bottom
or right before you hit the bottom you
can look way over the edge and we are
dangling over the edge
we can go whoa whoa whoa let's don't do
that
so let's don't
and i need some leaders in this country
to step up and say here's the new plan
we'll be right back with the doctor
jonathan show
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert and a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to hunter
in michigan ooh that sounds like a
like a character like from an awesome
movie or something i'm hunter from
michigan it's cool man what's up
not much john thanks for uh taking the
call absolutely brother how can it help
ma'am so i've been dealing with anxiety
and depression for a while now
but it's really been spiking before
work
almost every morning huh i'm waking up
with stomachaches throwing up
crying
just feel like i'm not comfortable
leaving the house yeah
so tell me about that
when you say for a while how long
so
the back in the day i guess i always
just called them nerves and when i say
back in the day i feel like
all the way to my youth
playing sports i always used to throw up
before the games because i was just so
nervous i just said it was nerves and
then i left high school where i felt
very comfortable and moved to college
that was a community college not far
from my home
and it was the biggest change and that's
when everything hit and when i actually
had to go to a doctor and
try and figure something out
so
man
what's your journey been like with the
doctors
um
you know
once i
i was diagnosed that freshman year of
college they put me on a medication
everything kind of started to get better
i ended up finishing college
and then covet hit
and
it was last year christmas time i hit
rock bottom there you go just i was just
talking about in that last segment about
man
we all started buzzing right
yep bam so how old are you now
i just turned 24.
so if you could paint a picture of what
you want your life to look like
give me some descriptions of that what
would that look like
i just um i want to find a job that i
enjoy that i
that it's not
40 hours of my week
uh 52 weeks a year just waiting for a
paycheck
i want to be secure i want to be with my
family i want to have time
man i hear it in you man and i want to
tell you i'm grateful for your bravery
it's hard to say that stuff out loud and
i'm grateful for you so i've been there
right where you're at
and so i want to start this whole
conversation by saying
i take no medication
not that that's bad i'm just telling you
there's
a there's a
light at the end of the tunnel
for me and it didn't involve medication
it does involve
a lot of laughter
and a lot of joy
and seasons when i run low
and i've come to accept that i don't
fight him anymore
and times when my body tries to get my
attention and i listen now i don't try
to ignore
and really it's been about charting my
own path over the last 10 15 years
so i want you to know there's healing on
the other side of this thing do you
believe me
i do yeah because i have hit like i said
rock bottom and then i feel
better you know i've i felt fine again
it's just you know what's what's going
on i'm not i'm not stressed at work
there's nothing really stressing me out
my job's not stressful um i think it's
just going to work yeah um i i might on
average say
three or four
sentences a day like good morning
good night
that's really it so all day you heard me
you may have heard me in the last
segment the
one of
one of the things things anxiety's an
alarm system right that just lets us
know that we're not safe and that we're
not connected or we are not in a
situation where we have any control
so i've said it a thousand times over
the last two years we should have some
anxiety going on
when we're just not allowed to work
because our mere presence can kill
somebody right
right um or when we think that we're
being lied to or cheated whatever the
thing happens to be you know
um
so
some of that anxiousness is normal it's
our body trying to get our attention
being like whoa we don't have any
control here guys and so
i've made peace with that
i appreciate my body trying to get to
keep me safe and get my attention
the two things you've mentioned
one is community college leaving high
school and going to community college
and then the other is
getting dropped into a job where you say
five or six sentences a day
where is your human interaction your
human connection these days
where is your friends
working
their work you know same
same thing i do monday through friday
and then i go home and i'm with my
fiance
and
i mean that's the interaction i get
pretty much during the day you know i go
home and see her
might see some of my family members they
all live pretty close but if i see my
friends most likely on the weekend
so the first thing i want you to do is
to make that
numero uno priority
i'm told i mean you and i are talking
for three minutes on the radio right so
i'm spitballing here
right but my hunch tells me that your
body senses it has lost its tribe
and if you can imagine 10 000 years ago
you woke up on the plains of
southern michigan and your tribe had
left you
you were probably gonna die
and your body would sound every alarm it
had to reconnect with other people get
up now run now
and find your tribe
and your body's telling you you're not
safe because you don't have anybody
um
can i ask you a hard question
yeah absolutely shoot
so when i was really crippled with this
with anxiety
i liked the feeling of alertness
i liked the feeling of always being in
the know of being ahead of the crowd if
you will
and over time i got chemically addicted
to that feeling of always buzzing
my body associated
rest with not being on guard
so rest wasn't a safe place for me rest
was a distressing place for me
do you
are you addicted to feeling anxious
yeah i might be honestly because i go to
bed thinking about what's going to
happen the next morning it's almost like
i know it's going to happen so okay so
let's just feel like
let's park there for a second what is
your body protecting you from at work
i'm not sure is there a chance you can
get fired
no are you or do you hate your job
no i don't hate it
do you hate what you're doing
um
yeah does your dad tell you you should
be doing something else or making more
money
no
nobody's really forcing me to do
anything or saying that i should change
just
you know
things come along when they should come
along
you don't believe that though
no i've always been
make it out
yes make it happen yeah i you know i
paint a picture and i'm gonna make that
picture happen i love it hunter but why
aren't you doing that in this case
scared i guess of what
not being secure not having a job
so right now you're trading security for
anxiety
is it worth it
[Music]
probably not it's not killing you and by
the way i painted you a false binary
picture there
i'm very secure in my job
and i'm not anxious anymore by the way
it's not at both i've had jobs where
i've not been anxious okay um working
with my friends you know growing up
through high school i worked with them
building fences and that was
a lot of fun but you had
community yes yeah andy let me let me
push on you you had someone to talk to
and right now for whatever reason you're
choosing not to talk
and that the demon of anxiety is it
spins you tighter and tighter to where
you feel like you're the only one
experiencing this thing and the way you
got to navigate the world is either
spewing on everybody or saying nothing
to anybody
do you vomit on your wife
i mean on your fiancee does she get a
big chunk of this
no
like she yeah she handles a brunt of it
i try not to because
we get married in a couple weeks and she
takes her
state boards actually today as we speak
and so here's what happens you're
hurting and you don't want to hurt her
with your hurt so you hold it back
and she feels a gap between the two of
you
which pushes her closer to you or
further away and that further signals
your anxiety alarms you see how this
thing just spins and spins and spins and
spins
spirals out of control that's right
so let me ask you this directly do you
want to be free
yeah
do you want to just lay down at night
and fall asleep
yeah my sleep latency now is less than
one minute you know what that means
that when my head hits the pillow i'm
out
can you imagine that
yeah
it's like a i remember when i was in the
throes of a dude it was like a fantasy i
didn't believe anybody had that
yeah
now my wife makes fun of me on friday
nights when we have family movie night
or something she's like it's family
movie night and john knapp night
because i i do i don't sleep anywhere
now it's incredible
yeah do you want that
i do okay and i think i think a lot of
it john stems from the job because i've
always said
people of i'm in school that you're
always taught what are you passionate
about what do you love to do try and
find a job to make money that way well i
loved
money and that's what kind of drew me to
the ramsey podcast and you and how i
even know about the show but
i
i feel like i don't know what i'm
passionate about or how to get
a job
like that too so make myself happier so
i want you to hang on the line i'm going
to get you two things i'm going to be my
gift to you i'm going to give you my
friend ken coleman's book from paycheck
to purpose and i'm going to give you his
career assessment too okay
that would be amazing and uh my friend
pat lencioni do you know that name
i do not he's the
one the greatest um executive coaches on
planet earth um he runs an extraordinary
consulting group one of the most highly
respected men in the industry
he has a working genius um instrument
that you can get for 25 percent off
um if you put in go to patincione.comy
and it's like 10 bucks or 18 bucks or
something like that i want you to do
that too
okay i can do that yeah
and
so those are a couple things i'm just
going to give you out of the gate do you
have a pin
um i do okay so i want you to write this
stuff down
this is 30
days number one do not stop taking your
medication are you still on now
yep okay good number two
no caffeine cut it out
yep okay are you already there
yeah so you don't you don't have any
caffeine in your life
no oh sweet cut your sugar way down you
already there
i should do better
not me dude i'm perfect just kidding i
just snort sugar off the counter with a
strong kid
all right what is your trigger besides
work
when i'm not in control
what does that feel like
uh
panicked
like i don't know what's going to happen
or when i don't know what's coming up
next because again i'm not in control
describe your body feeling to me
uh
stomach aches overwhelmed yeah you get
that warm feeling in your stomach it
drops
oh yeah and then your your chest
tightens way up
when that happens i want you to have a
note card with you that you keep at all
times
okay
and i want you to stop
and write down you may have to pull over
for 30 days okay
this is that important don't wait until
you get somewhere stop if you're walking
if you're at work you're in the middle
of a phone call so hey let me let me uh
put you on hold and i'll call you right
back
and i want you to write down right then
what am i not in control of whatever it
is
like you just thought about the weather
and you're like oh my gosh it could be
snowing and then ice and then i'm not
gonna be looking at my driveway and then
uh and that your body takes over i want
you to stop pull out that note card and
say i cannot control the weather
i will be safe driving home period
and here's what we're doing when your
body goes limbic when it sets off the
anxiety alarms it literally disconnects
part of your frontal lobe and again i'm
i'm making this as easy as possible
it trades
safety
i mean it trades speed for accuracy it
just starts spinning out all these
different and what you're doing when you
pull out this note card is you are
bringing your thinking brain back online
okay
and here this is a magic word write this
down in circle and put stars by it
you're gonna practice
you're just teaching your body a new way
to respond
okay
i got so anxious of the anxiety coming
and then i stopped doing things that
might be fun or exciting or a little bit
nerve-racking because i got scared of
the anxiousness
okay
i want you to begin to lean into those
things and just note when your body
takes off on you and then here's a magic
sentence to say
oh man
thank you for trying to take care of me
i'm good
you're right i can't control the stock
market or inflation i can't
i can't
and it will still do its thing for a
season
and in my experience over after working
with tons of p over time your body
begins to go oh he's in control of this
thing
okay
yep i want you to be militant about a
sleep routine
that means two hours before you go to
bed turn all the screens off for an hour
before you go to bed all screens off
read fiction not drama books or not
science books okay
go to the library and get some just
cheesy fiction
okay
i want you to give your brain a break in
the evenings and then this is the big
one
four times a day
do you live with your fiance
i do
four times a day skin on skin contact
not sexual doesn't have to be sexual
four times a day right when you wake up
right before you go to work right when
you get home right before you go to bed
skin on skin contact 10 to 30 seconds
okay
hold hands touch feet
whatever it is and i want you to slowly
begin to
drop your shoulders when you do it
that's it okay okay
and last one call some friends
say starting this monday every monday
night we're getting together and then
you know what they may tell you to screw
off let me say i'm not doing it don't
have time too busy whatever
that's a risk that you got to take and i
want you to keep going and keep going
you have to have a tribe not your fiance
not your family you got to get a gang
okay not a gang of weirdos there in
michigan either by the way
right join some crazy
lunatic group that wants to don't do
that
it won't good but
do find a group of guys you can go play
cards with or go bowling with or go to
arcade with or go serve the poor with do
something okay
is that fair
that's fair
you still see a counselor
i do okay have you ever said the words
i'm ready to stop
being anxious
um
i mean i've i feel like i've said yeah i
want this to end there you go yeah
there's no reason to stop there you go
so
when you say i want this to end i want
to feel better i want to not be anxious
anymore
our language is saying this is a thing
that's happening to us
when i take ownership and i say
i'm ready to stop being so anxious all
the time
now i'm gonna do things about my
thoughts
i'm gonna begin to change my thoughts
i'm gonna do things about my actions i'm
gonna change my actions and i'm gonna
live into a life
that is intentionally less anxious and
i'm gonna have to learn a new way of
living because i'm not gonna be
electrified all the time and let me tell
you
your body needs to be on guard because
you're not in control and i gotta
control gotta control gotta control
dude i'm telling you on the other side
of that the peace from not trying to
control everything is unbelievable
it's unbelievable
and this is the pot talking to the
kettle give yourself the opportunity to
live a life of peace
[Music]
all right your body can spin itself up
when it needs to and get a new job i
don't mean i don't say that flippantly
you gotta find a place to work right you
know that
yeah you do you know so i'm gonna hook
you up with ken coleman stuff and with
pat lucioni stuff i want you to check
out where you wanna be where you need to
be and then ken's book walks you through
the steps on how to get there i want you
to go make it happen cool thank you yeah
thank you very much brother there is
peace and healing on the other end of
this
there's a light at the end of that
tunnel my man there is we'll be right
back on the dr john delaney show
do you feel like you're always busy
doing something list chores work stuff
kid stuff pet stuff all of it but you're
never getting anywhere in the areas of
life you really care about like in your
relationships with friends taking care
of your body connecting with your spouse
a romantic partner loving your kids
then it's time to look at the things
you're doing and how your actions are
keeping you from where and who you want
to be if your actions aren't working for
you anymore that's okay
now's your chance to get up and choose
differently and that doesn't have to be
complicated in fact in my new book own
your past change your future we'll walk
through a common-sense approach to
mental health and wellness including
steps to change your actions and move
you closer towards the person you want
to be
if you pre-order today we'll give you
hundreds of dollars of free bonus items
so go to johndaloni.com to start
creating the life you want that's own
your past change your future at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back don't forget own
your past change your future at
johndelony.com go order the pre-sale
right now please order 50 of them that's
not really a hundred in nope order how
many
how many is ten thousand dollars divided
by twenty
james you're the ma i'm just kidding
don't do that just go go to johnalon.com
order the book i'm excited about it and
i know you will be too and order one for
all of your family members because
they're probably crazy too all right as
we wrap up today's show
led zeppelin baby one of the greatest
songs ever when the levee breaks it goes
like this
if it keeps on raining levy's gonna
break if it keeps on raining the levee's
gonna break dude this is about our
mental health situation in america right
now when the loving levee breaks we'll
have no place to stay mean old levy
taught me to weep and moan
mean old levy taught me to weep and moan
it's got what it takes to make a
mountain man leave his home oh well
don't make it feel bad when you're
trying to find your way home you don't
know which way to go
if you're going down south they got no
work to do if you're going north to
chicago
hey i don't even know what that song
means anymore but
that's the point of this show right here
on the dr john demoni's show